[Music]
many companies are on a journey evolving
their monoliths to microservices or even
managed micro services and I'll say many
companies but it's not always just a you
can't really think of a single company
is on this journey you have a lot of
different departments a lot of different
projects and each of them are kind of in
a different place on that journey some
projects some companies started from
someplace different maybe they started
from a service-oriented architecture was
sort of a half step along the way
towards microservices in Microsoft's
architectural pattern as you all know an
application is composed of finer grained
services that inter communicate via
these lightweight simple mechanisms that
are called api's the goals of this
increased product velocity manage
complexity of code perhaps polyglot
service construction where you've got
multiple languages different languages
implemented using being used to
implement different services and working
together and empowering developers in
order to advance business goals more
rapidly so that's all familiar to you
there is an alternative of course to
migrating a monolith in decomposing it
into a set of Micra services and that is
just wrap it just wrap it in a service
or in an API and call into that directly
just kind of freeze-dry it that way and
get access to it either way it's a
service it's just a coarser grained
service and you don't need to touch
things as much in fact in the keynote
yesterday we saw jennifer lynn
describing this exact scenario with one
of the tools that works with anthos
where you can take a VM where you've got
a system already running run this tool
and it pulls it into a container and
makes it host able in kubernetes engine
regardless of where you want to run it
so you kind of wrap it maybe one step
along the path of the strangler pattern
if you're familiar with that wrap that
monolith and just and put it wherever
you want in that container so a couple
of different options
neither are wrong many companies have
diff
projects that are traversing this path
in different directions the key thing to
remember is api's of the communication
contract so between the services that
are inter cooperating api's are the
things that allow those things to
communicate between clumps of services
or clusters of services maybe you've got
them structured in different meshes more
or less formally managed api's are used
and again between clients that are
external to your network to your meshes
its API so api's are the interface not
the implementation api's are the things
that allow people parties to interchange
information some of these api's may be
you know a really common structure for
api's as HTTP 1 and rest and maybe
you're going to use JSON for your data
format that is not presupposed by the
rest of what we're going to talk about
here that's a common one but that's not
the only one an API is just a
programmatic way to access the system so
we see a lot of people using HTTP 2 now
we see people using G RPC we see people
using graph QL and lots of other options
as well so API is just the communication
mechanism so let's take a I want to take
a moment to break down service mesh
infrastructure and look at what we want
out of that and to do that I want to
just take a step back and start from
from the basics now some of you may be
familiar with this teo maybe some of you
are running sto SEO is one one is in
production we've got some cv ease even
that we're updated so you've you've kind
of updated some vulnerabilities that
were discovered recently maybe you're
further along the path but maybe I
suspect that a lot of you are looking at
sto are examining services mesh
infrastructure are kind of building your
own services mash infrastructure with
different proxies maybe you're using
nginx maybe using H a proxy maybe you're
using linker D may be using envoy at its
base and you're less familiar with all
of what's going on in sto or in service
mesh in general so let's kind of take a
step back and just look at that so the
first thing is services intercommunicate
so we have a bunch of them in the
constellation intercommunicating we're
just going to look at two just for the
purposes of illustration here and we've
got that API that's it's kind of
these two once we have this connection
or decomposition of the monolith into
multiple different services things that
we had some assumptions about before
which is for example connection between
different modules is going to be in
process and secure those assumptions are
no longer accurate right no longer
applic applicable now the the different
modules are services are realized at
services and there is remote
communication between them so we need to
secure that so if you're going to go
into micro services one of the very
first things that you want to be able to
do is have mutual TLS so that both peers
in the exchange can authenticate each
other and you can perform authorization
decisions at the service level based on
the identity that's been asserted with
the TLS certificate so this is all just
kind of basic stuff but it's kind of
hard to do when you have when you have
just two services no problem you can
issue certs they can compare them you
can make sure this is the peer that I
expect and everything's good as you add
a number of services that starts to get
a little more complicated but for sure
you're gonna want that ideally one a
provision certs automatically so I'm at
remember keep in your mind we're looking
at just two but there's a constellation
of these things there's 15 there's 20
different cooperating services and I
want a provision search for all of them
and I wanted them to be distinct it's
cheating I know there's some of you out
there it's cheating to use the same
search for every service you can't do
that that's that's not the way it's
gonna work it's not gonna work well so
you need different serfs for each
service and and you'd like to have
policies in place as well for these
inter cooperating services what used to
be really easy just call the module it's
an improv
it's a method call I'm calling to a
different object what used to be super
easy is now I'm kind of maybe a little
bit iffy there's a network there the
network is ought not always present the
instance is not always there so you need
policies like am I going to retry this
call if I am going to retry how many
times what's the back off interval
what's the timeout at what point does
the client the initiator that call say
this has failed
I'm gonna read I'm gonna declare this
call failed and maybe retry or maybe
just give up how do i do circuit breaker
so if
continue to try to hit the same instance
and that thing is just not giving me
satisfactory response maybe it's no
connection at all but maybe it's just an
error I'd like to kind of take that out
of rotation and not connect to that
instance anymore if I'm doing services
mesh right I've got multiple instances
so I've got a different set of I can
connect to different ones but let me
just take that one out just flip that
circuit breaker and pull it out I want
to be able to do routing based on maybe
content or identity time of day
authorizations so all of those things
are sort of policies and there may be
more and you kind of want to implement
all of those in the disparate services
and remember each of these services we
may be talking about a polyglot
environment so while I am decomposing
let's say I've got a Java app or I've
got a dotnet app and I'm decomposing the
the Java code or the c-sharp code into
multiple different services then I can
say okay it's all one language super
easy but we all know that that's not how
it works in practice yes you're going to
decompose an existing system but then
there's a new team that's coming up and
they want to use a different language
they've got this Ruby module that does
just the right thing they've got Python
that they want to try they're much more
productive with that you're using nodejs
so you can't have all these provisions
all these policies implemented in all
those different languages in the same
way in a compatible way so the the the
thinking here is that rather than build
a library for each one of those
languages and platforms for Java for
c-sharp for Python and so on let's
factor out all that capability all that
smarts the the policy enforcement as I
talked about the EM TLS management the
session management maybe I've got
requirements for the particular
algorithms that are used in the in the
TLS connection let's factor that out and
put it in a proxy and it's one proxy
that works with everybody and we'll call
it a sidecar proxy so this is the model
that works in a scalable fashion for
services mesh infrastructure and in fact
this is the sto model this is the model
that sto uses it uses that sidecar proxy
it's actually implemented by a separate
open-source project called envoy all of
that stuff the TLS management the policy
enforcement all of that is done by
boy and your service you can implement
that in java.net nodejs it connects only
to the outside world either with inbound
or outbound communication via that proxy
via that sidecar proxy this is how sto
works an sto adds that control plane
that you see depicted in the bottom here
with a couple of different modules that
you can read about in the ischial
documentation this isn't a deep dive
into SEO but just kind of an overview
that's that allows certificates for
example to be provisioned for each
instance for each type of service in
your mesh and authorization rules to be
provisioned centrally and then sent out
to the proxy so that they can enforce if
I'm service B I'm gonna allow only
service a to call me I'm not gonna allow
service C to call me or any other new
service that gets introduced into the
mesh if you choose to restrict it that
way so those are the kinds of things
that the control plane for forest eoq do
in this mechanism you'll see those two
different diagrams data flow and control
metrics low the high throughput low
latency calls the things that are kind
of running your business are all
happening in the data plane one service
talking to the other lots of services
kind of connecting together you have
this mesh of services all inter
cooperating at very high speed that's
all happening in the data plane the
control plane is just separate it does
not get invoked for every communication
for every request most of that is cached
if you want to make a change and make it
in the control plane and then it gets
provisioned the proxies get updated and
they behave according to your
configuration on the next go-around
so ISTE also adds some other things
you're probably going to want to serve
as mesh and that is an ingress gateway
so now I've got this mesh and I'm
managing all the communications between
I've got TLS security so I'm encrypting
all the other point-to-point
communications i've got policy
enforcement i'm retrying the way I want
I've got back off intervals I've got
circuit breakers but I also want to
admit inbound communications to that
controlled mesh to the thing that I'm
managing nicely I want to have an
ingress gateway so sto adds this as well
as this concept and what it allows is an
internal client some other client
application that's not part of the mesh
to send in requests and again you can
have policies there too that allow you
can say
it needs to bear a JWT needs to be a
bear jot and it has to have this kind of
issuer or it needs to have TLS or it
needs to have mutual TLS and and the TLS
CN has to be such and such so you can do
all that with the ingress gateway as
well likewise you're going to want to be
able to control communication that is
that initiated from inside the services
mesh and sent outside in many in many
environments you know you just don't
care about that you've got network
firewall rules running somewhere but in
some you want to be even more careful
about that and you may want to do some
routing decisions so there's a way to to
manage outbound communications as well
and this is what we would call a managed
mesh of services or a service mesh some
people say I want to be particularly
about the definition of the term service
mesh some people think of service mesh
as you know SDO is a service mesh and
there may be other tools that are out
there other pieces of infrastructure
that are out there that you call a
service mesh the way I think about it is
a service mesh is a mesh of services
it's just a bunch of services that are
inter cooperating and intercommunicating
service mesh infrastructure is what
allows you to manage all that so that's
just my kind of phrasing but you'll hear
people throughout the conference say sto
is a service mesh it to me that feels
just a little bit inaccurate but I get
what they're saying in the rest of this
talk we'll be talking about service mesh
infrastructure and it shows a good
example of that
ok so just as something so that's kind
of a brief quick overview of service
mesh and this is why you would want to
use a service mesh it's connecting
securing controlling and observing the
services in that mesh next thing I want
to talk about is API management and it's
management for shared API so shared
api's may be wrapped around legacy
systems monoliths and what we want to be
able to do is allow external clients to
call into those systems why you use
management first discovery so an
external developer we want to allow
those external developers to see what
api's are available and then provision
credentials for use by that developer in
the apps they build in order to cut make
calls into the API gateway we want to
modernize systems we want a report and
we potentially want to monitor
api's on modernization specifically
we'll talk about a couple of different
scenarios here maybe you've got a soap
back in maybe you've got an XML back-end
you want to kind of make it look like
JSON or maybe you want to add caching
may want to add routing and
modernization it actually helps a this
aspect helps a lot when you're breaking
down the monolith as we'll see a little
bit later you can add routing right in
that API gateway layer pointing some
calls to the existing monolith and some
to the new microservices so this is what
it might look like as an evolution of
combining services mesh with API
management and API gateway so we've got
our API gateway external clients calling
through their internal clients calling
the systems that exist and we start to
introduce some micro services maybe
we're on that journey decomposing the
monolith into different micro services
and then maybe we're adding a few
services it's not just decomposing but
it's adding a few things it's augmenting
where we're modernizing and adding and
extending and so now the internal app is
going to be calling into the existing
monolith the new services and the API
gateway can kind of direct and route
calls in as we see fit we start to see
proliferation though and this is when
you're really going to benefit from that
services mesh infrastructure something
like STO and that's when you can create
these clusters use these clusters of
services and establish those policies in
all the things that I talked about in
the beginning of this session you can
have multiple different clusters
obviously they can run into the same
kubernetes cluster or different you can
run across clouds and Greg will actually
show you a little bit of multi cluster
scenarios this is what we think of as
the kind of clean model that composes
API management and service mesh
management or service mesh
infrastructure in an environment so this
is a clean picture super easy person
came up to me and said look I have a
question about maybe internal clients do
internal clients if they want to connect
to my system do they have to go out and
into the API gateway just to get into
the system and the answer to that is no
we already talked about the ingress
gateway that's part of SEO and you're
going to have that with any service mesh
infrastructure so internal clients can
continue to use those kinds of
approaches
but external clients for reasons we'll
get into will want to use probably want
to use something maybe a little more
structured in order to manage that
communication there this is the mental
model that I like to offer people when
they're thinking about how services and
api's work in an enterprise so at the
base level you have your infrastructure
that's going to be your platform as a
service your VMs may be its kubernetes
that you've chosen maybe it's a it's a
composite of those things you've got
different projects and different people
are using Cloud Foundry and who knows
you've got a bunch of different
infrastructure on top of that in some
way your building services and what we
like to say is there's gonna be
thousands of those depending on the size
of your company and you want to manage
those you want to wrap services
management around those now not all
services are going to be managed
it's an aspirational goal to have all of
them managed on exposed by those
services our api's and in the same way
we aspire to have the thousands of
services be under management we aspire
to have the api's that gets shared out
of those services not the ones that
they're using to inter communicate
within the mesh but the ones that get
shared out we aspire to have those under
management too not all of them will be
there are some pitfalls associated to
not managing your api's and Greg and I
can both attest to that but that's the
aspiration so that's the model platform
thousands of services hundreds of those
maybe exposing shared api's that get
consumed by clients that are either
inside the company but distant from the
teams that are producing or outside of
the company some external client and
that's the the mental model now with
that I'm going to hand it over to Greg
and he's going to kind of make this real
for us with demonstration awesome Thank
You Dino all right so I'm gonna go
through this pretty quick in the
interest of time but I want to set up
with a little bit of background in terms
of what you're gonna see in the
demonstration of course we're gonna use
the proverbial Acme company what haven't
they done they're pretty typical
enterprise they've got different
departments divisions locations today
we're going to concentrate on two teams
we're going to concentrate on the
product team
manage things like products product
catalog and logistics team they manage
the warehouse delivery those sorts of
things
now Acme is feeling a lot of pressure
from startups kind of trying to disrupt
the market and the businesses ask IT to
move faster so what the product team the
logistics team took a look and they said
you know what maybe if we modernize a
couple of these existing monoliths we
can move faster and they made their some
decisions they chose to go with a
kubernetes based system using service
mesh infrastructure and API management
the product team has three services that
we're looking at here they have their
product service and then a location and
a pricing service the main consumer of
the product service is a mobile app it's
an internally developed mobile app
you'll notice in this case that mobile
app is actually going through an
external API gateway in this case the
Apogee API gateway that happens to be
running as SAS in the cloud
the logistics team has an inventory
service they also have a third party
that accesses that inventory service
that helps them and needs accurate
inventory counts so with that let's get
started with the demo can we go to the
demo please all right so we talked about
the product team that's what we're gonna
start they are using kubernetes and they
made the what is the obvious choice for
where to run kubernetes which is gke so
they've got a few different clusters
here the cluster that we're going to
worry about today is this dual cluster
one it's a four node cluster and let's
just take a look and see what they've
actually got running in there so you'll
see just like what we would expect to
see we've got a product service a
pricing service and a location service
those are the pods that are running in
this cluster so at first they kind of
built these services and everything was
great and then they had the operations
team the security team come along and
started asking questions about hey how
is communicates with Wedge how do i view
the logs all of that stuff so they
decided that you know they're developers
they could develop libraries and build
all this stuff into their services but
they didn't want to do that so they
chose to use SEO as their service mesh
infrastructure to handle all those
things
so let's just take a look and see what
they've got running from an SEO
perspective in here and you'll forgive
me I'm just gonna copy all my commands
because otherwise you'll see lots of ID
10t errors as I tried to type in and if
you don't know what ID 10t is you can
type that into your phone figure out
what that is so you'll see here there's
a bunch of pods running for sto then
enable the service mesh you'll see
things like Citadel and pilot that you
also saw up on Deano's diagrams up there
and so now what I actually want to do is
I'm gonna go on a slate a small tangent
very briefly so previously in my career
I worked for a logistics company and
what one of the things I was responsible
for was handling all external
communications with third parties
customers what have you now occasionally
we'd have to set up a mutual TLS
connection with one of these third
parties that was pretty much always my
option of last resort I hated it and it
usually was something like this so we'd
get on a call and sometimes I'd have to
explain to them why I wouldn't create a
private cert for them and then we'd
exchange certs and I'd load the key on
my side and they'd send something in and
they'd I'd say they say it's not working
and I say well you sent me why but I see
you're actually sending me X when you
send it and they'll say no no we're
sending why there's no way we're sending
X and that would go on from anywhere
between an hour to two weeks so now I
want to enable that same feature within
sto for our different components just a
little bit of setup here I've got
another container that is sitting in a
namespace that is not sto injection
enabled so I'm gonna connect into that
container just to show you how it calls
the pricing service all right I'm in
that container and I'm going to make a
call to our pricing service and you'll
see actually it worked right so that's
interesting this isn't participating in
the mesh but it worked well right now
we're in what we call permissive MPLS
state and what that is is as you're
first printing services into your
service mesh you may have services that
are outside that can't communicate with
that and so anything that's in the
service mush is automatically going to
establish an MPLS connection but
anything outside can continue connect
any
it did before alright so with that I
actually do want to change this to
strict now and I'm going to show some
yeah Mille there's only two times that I
show llamo I'm sure if you guys have
been to sessions here you've seen lots
of llamo probably so far in this
conference I have just a couple of very
simple
yeah moles that I'm going to show so
this is the rule if I want to make it
strict M TLS and basically all this is
saying is that for the pricing service I
want to set the MPLS mode to strict so
let's go ahead and apply that yes maybe
is that a little better yeah okay so we
applied that let's go back into our
container and let's attempt to access
that service again as you see did not
work so I'll tell you honestly every
time I do this it brings me joy I didn't
have to create a certificate
I'd have to set it up I don't have to
negotiate with anyone it just worked
that alone is like the word worth the
price of entry into sto and service mesh
infrastructure okay
but let's change pace here for a second
we talked about the fact that the main
consumer of this product service was the
mobile app so how does the mobile app
the mobile app obviously isn't
participating in a service match so how
does it get access to these things well
that's where API management comes into
play what you're looking at here is a
developer portal built using Apogee
technology this is just the landing page
I'm gonna kind of get into this pretty
quickly so I want to see what api's are
available you'll see there's a product
API and a product catalog API and
inventory API so let me click into the
product catalog API there's some
documentation here so just briefly all
of this documentation is being built off
an open API spec version 3 that open API
spec is actually hosted in the Appaji
spec editor so that's just kind of how
this is happening in the
groan so I want to actually give this a
try I'm the mobile app developer now I
want to give it a try but I see it
there's some sort of authentication
required so let's see how do I actually
do that so I'm just going to go to the
Quick Start you see okay I see I've got
a sign-in register some apps I know that
already so I've done that I've created
an account and I've created some apps
I'm just going to click into this first
app here see a couple of pieces of
information there are some API keys and
then there's a couple of products that I
can choose from this point I need to
back up just a second because I've
introduced a couple of important
concepts here from an API management
perspective one developer this is our
API consumer right so this is the
audience of this developer portal so I
created a developer account a developer
wants to have access to API so developer
creates an app and an app is what
provides that developer access when they
create an app they will see different
products that they can select now what's
a product and why do we call it a
product so a product is nothing more
than a collection of api's maybe sub
resources within an API maybe just one
API and basically it's the way within
app a G's API management to select what
the app is allowed to actually access
and why do we call it a product well
we've found that companies that are the
most successful with their API programs
they treat their API is like products
what does that mean they have a product
manager they use outside in thinking so
they develop their API is with the API
consumer in mind they don't just say hey
I've got a system it's got six fields
I'm going to expose those six fields and
that's my API so just some important
concepts and and in terms of API
management so I want to actually execute
that I'm gonna copy Mikey I'm gonna go
back over to the API I want to just
execute this products here I want to
authorize this click here and I want to
enter my key oh wait I don't even have
to enter my key since I'm logged in it
knows who I am
it knows what apps I have I'm just gonna
select that app I'll click authorize and
then go ahead and execute and you'll see
that I get a response back from the
product service so right within the
developer portal the developer can try
it out now I want to make a point here
and this is that the mobile team never
talked to the product service team they
didn't have to figure out how to do this
they came here it was completely
self-service the product team didn't
have to be involved at all and allowing
them to access this API so that's API
management
all right so let's try to go ahead and
access that without an API key through
the app just to prove that indeed it is
going to fail I got to get out of that
container all right so failed to resolve
the API key no surprise there
let's go ahead and do that with the API
key and I'm sorry my fonts gonna get
smaller here because I've got a bunch of
different screens but nonetheless you'll
see that it got a response and then what
I wanted to show here in the upper right
hand corner this is the product service
so you see we lit up the product service
and then the product service actually
called the pricing service as well one
more thing I kind of want to show here
and that is what happens if I grab a
specific product so I'm gonna come back
over to my shell here so you'll see here
again we lit up the product service we
load up the pricing service and in this
case we lit up the location service as
well so these are all running in the
mesh they're all protected by M TLS and
that kind of covers the product team so
I'm gonna move quickly over to the
inventory and so let's see here let's
let's take a look at what these guys
have so the inventory team again same
thing they're running on gke they have
their very own project their very own
cluster their very own mesh we're gonna
go ahead and connect into that one now
so I'm just gonna copy the command to
set my credentials go ahead and execute
that create some space for us over here
and then I want to take a look at the
logs for the inventory service second
and you'll see that indeed we had a hit
over to the inventory service here as
well so let's go over here so what does
that mean well it means that the pricing
the product service called over to the
inventory service right and we know that
there is external access to this at
so let's just try to go ahead and access
this same guy from outside and see what
happens so if we go there we see uh it's
the permissions tonight the apogee is do
adapter in this case denied that and
it's looking for an API key so wait a
second what does that mean how did the
product service call into the inventory
service well the way these meshes are
set up they're actually a dual control
plane setup what does that mean means
you've got two separate UCL meshes but
they're essentially acting as one mesh
and the way that that's done is through
some magic with the core DNS as well as
sharing a root certificate authority and
what we essentially do is we create a
service entry that advertises the
services that we're going to be calling
and I'm going to go ahead and show you
what that looks like here and this
service entry in this case is actually
going to be deployed in the product
cluster because they're calling out to
the inventory cluster so just two things
I want to point out in this little EML
so one is the host so its inventory
service default which is the namespace
dot global which is saying hey this
isn't in my local mesh I need to go look
somewhere else for this and then I'm
going to point out this endpoint address
here that's actually the ingress gateway
so you remember Dino talked about the
ingress gateway that's actually the
ingress gateway to the logistics team's
mesh where the inventory service is
running so it's just that simple
it calls over their mutual TLS works
across these meshes just the way it does
within an individual mesh so now that
said let's go ahead and grab a curl with
a key here just to show that indeed you
can also access this from outside the
mesh and indeed so we called with the
API key and you'll see we got a Product
ID and a quantity back from the
inventory service so that my point that
I want to make with that is it's getting
the full benefits of API management that
third party could go into the developer
portal just like we saw for the mobile
app get their key all of those things
but it's calling it it's not coming
through the sass gateway in this case
it's going directly to the mesh and the
app G is geo adapter is verifying that
key as well as as well as sending
analytics back to Apogee
to report upon to the gateway itself so
with that it almost wraps up the demo
there's just one other thing that I want
to talk about briefly
and that is the product team as they
were going through they're actually
modernizing and they had an existing
service that was serving up the product
catalog is actually a fairly modern
service is restful in nature but they
wanted to change the API they wanted to
they wanted they made some breaking
changes to the API as they were
modernizing so the first thing they did
is they used the Apogee gateway and they
actually use that to mediate and expose
that API in the new version to some some
new customers that wanted to come in and
use that in that way so that's the first
thing they did before they actually
built the service and then they start to
build this new service in the service
mesh here and they use the apogee
gateway to actually help with the
migration process and one of the ways
that they do that is they've got
basically they based on the client
that's calling in they can set up and
say hey a % is going to go to either the
old service of the new service and they
can slowly roll to the new service that
way so the app that I've been using so
far has been set to 100% the new service
but I actually have another key that
calls it's set to 50/50 so it's doing a
bit of math it's not always exactly
50/50 it's random in nature but we'll go
ahead and try to call this a couple of
times in this case it looks like it's
gonna be exactly 50/50 so you've seen my
first response there that was the modern
service we've done meet it up a little
bit here for the demo it's got a smaller
response block it's go a little faster
the second one is actually going to the
legacy service it's got a bigger
response block just so you see that now
if we could switch back to the slides
please all right so just a very quick
recap and you know I went through that
pretty quickly so mobile app calling
through the API gateway to get to the
product service that product service is
living inside of a service mesh that
service mesh that product service is
actually calling out to another service
in a completely separate service mesh
but through the dual control plain setup
it's actually acting as one service mesh
and then there's a third-party that
again calls to that inventory service
but it doesn't go through the gateway it
uses the app to sto adapter with that
I'm gonna call Dino back up on stage
because I've got some questions for him
so my first question is when do I need
service mesh infrastructure so my
opinion on this is anytime you have a
significant number of cooperating micro
services get a service mesh
infrastructure in place because you want
that M TLS I thought you're gonna throw
this to me just thinking about it
thrown at you will scared there for a
minute you want that mutual TLS you want
to be able to secure the communications
between the two peers or many many
different peers and that becomes really
important and you get if you get is teo
then you get a bunch of other things for
free the observability the aggregated
logs and some other things okay well
that's fine but you know my consumers
they need a response pretty quickly what
about latency there's it's magic there
is no additional latency oh that's
awesome you heard it here first folks no
additional latency no actually okay so
let me just correct that just a little
bit is a little adjustment there is a
little bit of latency small but you're
not gonna you're not going to notice it
it's so small invisible no seriously
there there will be some latency there's
an extra hop there's a proxy there you
guys all saw it in the picture so
there's gonna be a hop there and but
it's a sidecar so that proxy resides in
the same pod with the service so the hop
to the proxy is going to be relatively
quick the hop that the proxy makes to
the other proxy that's the same hop that
was there in the first place so the only
change is really the in pod hops that go
from proxy service and service to proxy
and that we think it's gonna be small
like sub microsecond illah second if if
you have it depends obviously on load
but the question you got to ask is is
the latency cost which is real worth the
benefits that you get and we think it is
okay so is the takeaway from this then
that if there's a mobile client then use
API management it's not almost always
yeah that's almost always the case now
if you have mobile clients that's not
the only reason to use API management
mobile clients in particular introduce
factors that you're going to want
API management to kind of handle the
perimeter security that is required for
mobile clients it's beyond just TLS
enforcement or JWT verification you
might want to do things like
malicious content filtering or XML bomb
detection or adaptive rate limiting or
Pat traffic pattern analysis and maybe
even token binding where if you get an
OAuth token you can bind it to a
particular TLS sir so lots of things on
the perimeter API management makes a lot
of sense for that
perfect so then what I'm hearing is any
external client uses API manager yep
probably probably if you have external
clients that means traffic is coming
from outside those clients are going to
be outside of your control so even if
it's a client that let's say you built
as a company and you're giving it to
consumers it's running on consumer
mobile apps as soon as you do that
there's gonna be a hacker there's gonna
be a bunch of hackers that kind of
decompile that thing and figure out
what's going on and figure out the
reverse engineer in the API so they're
gonna be sending in API is that look
just like bonafide api's which is why
you want that perimeter security so
almost always okay this is API
management makes sense all my clients
are internal so if they're all internal
probably not but I think that scenario
that you just raised seems to be
unlikely so the trend is towards more
and more connection more and more
clients you know any entity any company
any organization that is digitally
isolated is not going to thrive so
there's got to be some desire to have
inbound communications now a project a
project may be serving only internal
clients and in that case yeah you
probably don't need a PR management for
that but when you have external clients
it sure makes sense and before I get to
my next question you know one of the
things I like to say with that is that
your internal API today is your external
API tomorrow yeah just don't realize it
and I've seen that over and over again
with customers yeah you build company
builds an API and gets a lot of use and
somebody some product manager or
executive says you know what we should
extend that to this partner over here it
is now external so you're gonna rapidly
new need API management that so my next
question is kind of like don't I get API
management
servus mesh infrastructure yes you get
some of the features of API management
in the service mesh infrastructure you
so you get authentication you get the
TLS capability you get observation and
access control but as we said in
particular in those things that you
showed you want to self-service enable
developers to go figure out what api's
are available get credentials and embed
those credentials into their apps it's
not always going to be an API key might
be a different set of credentials it
might be a public/private key pair that
you're issuing as credentials but you
want to have that be self-service you
don't want to have people emailing
around saying hey I need credentials and
here we're gonna send it an email that's
not secure it you know that's not the
way to do it you also need a different
set of reporting monitoring for api's
that are being used by external clients
shared api's you know business people
are going to want to see what's the
trend in the number of developers that
are using my API is a number of
different partners or for errors you
know is there a particular developer
that is that is build API is that is
causing more errors different kinds of
monitoring and reporting is enabled by
an API management platform that's
probably not something you want on the
internal API so you do get some API
management capability and service
mission infrastructure but it's probably
not enough when you start to share out
okay
so there's some overlap there so I'm
gonna go back to latency again my
consumers are super demanding don't I
get a latency incurred with API
management latency free zone we it's yes
Wow magic press no so there there is
obviously a latency every time you add
an additional hop there's a latency what
we showed in the demo what you showed
was a cloud-based API management gateway
so it's running somewhere on an external
endpoint accessible to the Internet
magic anything that was calling in had
to go through the public network get
into that gateway and then into the
internal mesh yeah or the services in
the mesh so yep there's a if you have an
internal client and it's doing that it's
going out the public network coming in
through that gateway and there's going
to be a hop there so yes there can be
but not necessarily so at this
conference
as you know we've announced the avail
the beta availability of the Apogee
hybrid gateway which is the same gateway
that we just saw you demonstrate okay
same capabilities but it is able to run
inside the kubernetes cluster so it's
not a sidecar it's not running right
next to the service it's still a shared
gateway but it's in the cluster which
means it's on the local network it's
gonna be fast it's gonna be low latency
and you're gonna be able to stay on the
private network so if you have sensitive
traffic there's no regulatory issue
there as well
that's cool yeah really nice so yes
there's some latency again go with a
cost-benefit analysis and there's a
mitigation where you can run that
gateway inside the kubernetes cluster so
I think we may have covered this but do
all of the API requests hop out onto the
public network I think maybe we covered
this so the answer is not necessarily
if you use the apogee SAS service today
it's going to happen but if you run that
that gateway inside then then you don't
what about if you're required so sto is
something that you used and it does I
kind of broke it down did a quick
overview of what it does it's not
actually required in order to manage
services you can manage services
different companies use different things
they they may use kind of their own
approach they may use H a proxy they
mean you just nginx and couple that with
some log aggregation tools and call that
their services mesh there's nothing
wrong with doing that in fact if a
company is large enough there's going to
be heterogeneity and the approaches that
they've taken so it's not absolutely
required that you do is do we think SEO
is a good idea it's being built to
address you know the 80% case at least
for most people so we think it's worth
looking at but it's not absolutely
required you can still do services mesh
with your own toolset and compose that
with API management according to the
patterns that we just described that
still is going to work great okay
so kind of I think this may be my last
question but this sounds like super
complicated do I really need all of this
stuff nope you don't need it if you
don't want to conduct business you don't
all right awesome yeah there we go and
on that notice look as soon as you have
multiple services you're gonna want the
capabilities of a service mesh
infrastructure you're gonna want that
you want to protect the secure the the
transmissions between them and like
that's the best way to do it as soon as
you start sharing api's you're going to
want
API management software now if your
startup sure be thoughtful about the
things the components the tools that you
embed into your architecture you know
you don't want to build the world at
first maybe you're on this MVP approach
okay I get it maybe you can economize
minimize kind of do it yourself on
different things if you're an enterprise
you're a big company you have governance
requirements you got regulatory
requirements you need tools
infrastructure to help you govern and
manage and control those sorts of things
and you're probably going to need both
of these in the right doses now so this
is how we think they compose and and
this is probably a good recommendation
for most big companies it's not about
you know having cool tools and cool
infrastructure and I like cool tools
yeah I know you do it's it's about
getting things done more quickly
you know composing service mesh
infrastructure and API management allows
the business to innovate more quickly
and that's what we're talking about here
awesome
so with that kind of back-and-forth
dialogue Greg and I tried to summarize
the decision criteria for when you want
to use more or less API management I
think the call on services management is
really simple if you have more than just
a handful of services you're going to
want some service mesh infrastructure
you're gonna want something like SEO at
least envoy or some other proxy and
you're probably going to want a control
plane as well it's Joe's worth looking
at but for API management it's a little
board more nuanced where you apply it is
maybe interesting as we said big
enterprises are probably going to be
using it but the question is where at
what layer at what interface and these
are some of the decision criteria kind
of summarizing what we what we just
talked about
[Music]